hey Mary here with a gamespot news  update today was announced that Sean is  a huge mother fall hey Mary here with a  gamespot news update today it was  announced that remakes of the game boy  advance games pokemon ruby and sapphire  will be coming to the Nintendo 3ds later  this year ruby and sapphire are being  re-released as Omega Ruby and alpha  sapphire and the pokemon company said  they would be released in November even  though these are remakes and not an  entirely new saga the company said the  new titles promised to take players  through a dramatic story within a  spectacular new world they also said an  epic new adventure is coming so it  sounds like there's going to be some  surprises the game is in 2d but some  areas will also be playable in 3d  Pokemon x/y had mostly 2d gameplay  except battles and certain areas so that  could have been expected now that's all  we know for now but we'll keep you up to  date with all the exciting Pokemon news  right here at gamespot com